unsere demokratie ist herausgefordert
in vielen ländern werden auf
demokratischem weg autokraten gewählt
die ihrerseits die demokratie verachten
die größeren probleme wie die klimakrise
oder die zuwanderung sind
nationalstaatlich nicht zu bewältigen
ganz offenbar müssen wir neu über uns
aus gesellschaft nachdenken
und genau das wollen wir heute tun schön
sind sie dabei meine beiden gäste fallen
derzeit auf mit eigenwilligem
gesellschaftsanalysen die wir ins
gespräch bringen wollen
zu gast ist die soziologin cornelia
koppetsch sie ist professorin an der
technischen universität darmstadt sie
sagt wir erleben gerade einen epochalen
umbruch den wir als konterrevolution
gegen globalisierungsprozesse verstehen
müssen und bei uns ist der philosoph
dieter thoma er ist professor an der
hochschule st gallen er meint ist
mangels derzeit an wahren helden und
plädiert für einen zeitgemäßen heroismus
herzlich willkommen
herzlich willkommen ja ja wir beginnen
mit den sperrigeren vorschlag von ihnen
herr tun nämlich mit der these die
demokratie brauche neue helden um sind
helden etwas wo ich erst mal denke an
verstaubte museen
wir haben hier nicht besonders verstaubt
aber wir haben hier den georg mit dem
ritter ein großer held was ist von
heldenfiguren wirklich zu erwarten heute
ich glaube schon dass wir selten stauben
sollten die helden wir haben uns so
eingerichtet in einer komfortzone der
demokratie bei der man dachte der laden
läuft für alles ist gesorgt es gibt die
polizei
es wird alles geregelt und diese
komfortzone ist offensichtlich
zusammengebrochen wir haben
krisensymptome überall und jetzt ist die
frage sollen wir dann diesen helden
begriff der natürlich von machos und
kriegern dominiert worden ist über viele
jahrhunderte aber nicht ausschließlich
beherrscht wurde sagen wir den einfach
den autoritären regimes überlassen oder
hollywood und ich glaube dass
das gut passt zur demokratie dieser
helden weil demokratie auch viel mit
bewegung und tatkraft zu tun hat ich bin
extrem gespannt sein wohin uns das
gespräch führen wird
sie haben an ihrem buch die ihr neues
buch warum demokratien helden brauchen
er gibt es eine passage vielleicht das
noch kurz vorne weg weil mich das
interessiert was sie beschreiben das im
ersten weltkrieg ist eine firma gab in
deutschland die hat so denk mal raus sie
produziert also in dieser art hier und
dann konnte man sich den passenden hält
bestellen dem man gerne darauf schrauben
wollte welchen hält würden sie denn ganz
kurz venen für sich dadurch 2
weil er so ein eigenwilliger kerber und
dann doch zum mitglied des bundes wurde
und rosa parks die den bus boykott und
die bürgerrechtsbewegungen usa ausgelöst
hat denn die hat diesen wunderschönen
satz gesagt dass sie von ihrer
entschlossenheit wie von einem dicken
mantel in einer kalten winternacht
umschlossen worden ist also man spürt da
wächst jemand über sich hinaus frau
kopetzky haben ja nicht so mit den
helden und heldinnen aber auch am sie
noch die frage wenn sie wählen müssten
was würden sie auf schrauben
ich würde etwa zu nehmen und greta
thonberg aber ich wie gesagt ich bin
überhaupt nicht so viel helfen und ich
würde eher sagen
die frage die also ich habe auch
überhaupt nichts gegen machos aber die
frage die sich mir stellt in dem helden
thema ist weniger ob helden gut oder
böse sind oder ob sie jetzt in der
demokratie uns raus helfen können
sondern ob sie überhaupt relevant sind
und diese frage würde ich verneinen also
sie sind so lange irrelevant wie unsere
demokratie funktioniert so lange wie die
demokratie funktioniert sind sie nicht
relevant sind sie nicht relevant
aber da müssen wir da ja genau ein haken
denn es gibt ja eine these die auch bei
ihnen beiden auftaucht nämlich dass die
demokratie gerade nicht funktioniert die
steckt nämlich in der krise
sie sagen sogar in der größten krise
seit 1940
ich glaube dass der satz die demokratie
funktioniert was sowas ist wie ein
widerspruch in sich
weil demokratie
nie einfach funktioniert wie so ein
toaster oder so ein computer oder so
demokratie ist eigentlich immer eine ein
prozess eine bewegung die getragen wird
von menschen die sich einsetzen und
nicht nur von institutionen die
irgendwie wie am schnürchen laufen und
deshalb glaube ich es ist sowieso so
dass demokratie immer so was wie
tatkraft und anziehungskraft von leuten
braucht und als kristallisationspunkte
und abgesehen davon ist es natürlich so
dass die demokratie tatsächlich im
moment irgendwie so ein bisschen wie so
ein hohler körper wirkt wo die belegung
von innen und auch also leidet und die
bedrohung von außen wächst und insofern
können wir uns ja einigen wenn die
demokratie nicht funktioniert braucht
helden da die demokratie nie einfach nur
funktioniert brauchen weil sie dann doch
eher für die frage wie wir diese krise
auch an überhaupt analysieren und da
kommt sozusagen ihr buch ins spiel
sie haben ein buch vorgelegt das wurde
sehr viel diskutiert in jüngster zeit
die gesellschaft des törns
rechtspopulismus im globalen zeitalter
ich habe den globus sozusagen aus
gegenbild zum helden dahin gestellt sie
sagen tatsächlich die globalisierung die
hat sich in einer art und weise
entwickelt dass wir jetzt in einer krise
der demokratie leben wir müssen von
einer konterrevolution gegen die
globalisierungsprozesse sprechen wenn
über den populismus sprechen
das müssen wir jetzt glaube ich erst mal
ein bisschen verstehen ja genau also das
ist vielleicht auch deshalb ein
mehrschichtiges problem weil die
globalisierung hat eben die demokratie
aus den nationalstaatlichen halterungen
herausgelöst also wir haben auf der
politischen ebene über staatliche
gebilde wie die eu oder auch die
freihandelsabkommen die aber eben nicht
mehr in dem sie eine demokratisch
funktionieren wie wir das von unseren
regierungen gewohnt sind weil ja nicht
mehr demokratisch gewählt werden
der zweite aspekt der globalisierung wie
inhalte dass wir es mit transnationalen
unternehmen zu tun haben die sehr sehr
mächtig geworden sind und die mächtiger
geworden sind als die staaten das heißt
sie können den staaten vorschreiben
unter welchen bedingungen sie
13 sich in den staaten anzusiedeln die
staaten müssen auf die bedingung
eingehen
das ist der zweite aspekt und der dritte
ist das durch globalisierung die
gesellschaften auch im inneren
vielfältiger geworden sind stichwort
migration frauen die aufgestiegen sind
diversity pluralisierung von
lebensformen das alles sind dinge die
eben dazu geführt haben dass das was
früher so eine stilbildende
mittelschicht war die also im
nationalstaatlichen container auch sich
praktisch herausgebildet hat dass das so
nicht mehr existiert sondern von allen
seiten sozusagen durch gelüftet worden
ist und das ist nicht notwendig das
wirklich von allen menschen als
krisenerfahren aber von einigen
bevölkerungsgruppen schon nämlich von
denen die von der globalisierung nicht
profitieren
und hier müsste man erst mal einsetzen
meines erachtens und das sind meines
erachtens probleme die man durch keine
heldentat lösen kann ja wenn ihr noch
ganz kurz bei der analyse auch bleiben
können zusammen gesagt nicht alle
bevölkerungsschichten finden dass
problematischen könnte man ja mit dem
toaster bei stillem sagen naja eben
demokratie ist nicht wie ein toaster
funktioniert oder funktioniert nicht
sondern entwickelt sich immer worin
besteht denn das problem wenn eine
bevölkerungsschicht findet für mich ist
das mit der demokratie nicht so gut
das problem ist ja dass ja jede
gesellschaftsordnung auf konsens
angewiesen ist also damit leute sich an
die regeln halten an die spielregeln die
in einer gesellschaft existieren bedarf
es eine einer grundüberzeugung eines
grundvertrauen zu gehen in die
politische verfassung in die politische
gemeinschaft eines gemeinwesens und wenn
zu viele menschen frustriert werden sei
es weil sie diese gesellschaft als
ungerecht empfinden weil sie in ihren
aufstiegen blockiert werden weil sie in
die industrie edition die
industrialisierten zonen abgehängt ich
fühlen oder weil sie einfach mit mit der
digitalisierung nicht mehr mitkommen
werden diese frustration zu groß wären
dann entziehen sie in konsens und fangen
an sich nach anderweitigen muss dann
modellen
ausschau zu halten und das sind in dem
fall aber nicht die charismatischen
führungsfigur sondern wir haben ja
gerade einer starken der rechts parteien
die sich populistisch nennen und die
eben auf eine volks also ein volks
kollektiv sich berufen und nicht so sehr
auf einzelne hellen gestalten
von daher glaube ich dass hier also
diese gegenbewegung auch nicht also
faktisch zumindest also das mag eine
schöne fantasie sein dass man vielleicht
eine heldenfigur braucht die uns davon
befreit aber fakt ist dass die jetzt
existierende demokratiekrise gar nicht
auf die helden zurückgreift sondern auf
populistische bewegung die auf
kollektive identitäten raccuglia ich
glaube es ist noch komplizierter weil
ich würde sagen nicht jeder hält ist
demokratisch aber demo kathrin brauchen
helden
das heißt gerade diese populistischen
bewegungen bei deren analyse ich ihn
total folge gibt es ja häufig gerade
auch diese führungsfiguren sei es jetzt
an der regierung sei es irgendwie auf
den bei demonstrationen die dann in
diesen gruppen auch helden als helden
angesehen werden das heißt meinen helden
begriffs ja nicht unkritisch ich will ja
nicht einfach irgendwie helden sondern
ich will den hätte mich fragen sollen
wie hat als demokraten den helden
begriff diesen autoritären bewegungen
überlassen und typischerweise ist es ja
so dass diese massen von denen sie da
sprechen eben sich dadurch dadurch
gekennzeichnet sind dass sie eben
relativ plumpes verhältnis der
unterordnung der gefolgschaft zu diesen
führungsfiguren haben und das ist
natürlich nicht im sinne der demokratie
aber man kann sich auch vorstellen
ja also letzten endes stehen wir vor der
alternative sollen wir jetzt praktisch
diese dieses volk diese volksbewegung
als dumpfe masse mit autoritären führer
die irgendwie verlust erfahrungen machen
diese ernst zu nehmen sind sollen wir
die jetzt zum beispiel den ganzen
individuellen
von den über erfolgreichen gewinner der
globalisierung gegenüberstellen
ich glaube was wir brauchen ist so was
wie eine antiautoritäre gemeinschaft von
der eine demokratie lebt und da daleiden
die demokratien im moment ja wenn ich
also ich würd zwei sachen dazu sagen
wollen einmal ja sie haben recht wir
brauchen etwas was uns von diesem
neoliberalismus der ja post heroisch ist
befreit weil das was der neoliberalismus
uns ja die ganze zeit erzählt oder auch
die subjekte die aale die im
neoliberalismus verkörpert sind nämlich
der flexible mensch oder das
unternehmerische selbst oder auch das
kreativ subjekt das ist ja nichts
anderes als das plädoyer zur anpassung
also konformismus konformität oder
vielleicht auch opportunistisch wenn man
böse ist ja das heißt was da fehlt ist
ja genau das was der held uns liefert
nämlich eine transzendenz das heißt eine
sinn orientierung die über das einzel
subjekt und seine egoismen oder über die
reine nutzen orientierung des marktes
hinausweist und genau das fehlt uns ja
genau frauke fischer sind jetzt ganz
viele fachbegriffe die vielleicht auch
schwer einzuordnen wir lassen sie uns
vielleicht über den neoliberalismus und
er über die gefahr des konformismus der
anpassung später noch einmal sprechen
aber sie wollten wir auch darauf
reagieren ob eigentlich von den helm
etwas zu erwarten ist ja von den helden
ist schon was zu erwarten also der held
ist ja nichts anderes als der
charismatische führungsfigur und aber
was glaube ich problematisch ist wenn
wir von dem hält die lösung für den
antagonismus antiautoritär ismus suchen
weil der held ist ja gerade das was zur
identifikation also zur distanzlosen
identifikation einlädt und damit gerade
nicht unbedingt emanzipatorisch und
damit gerade nicht das was wir unter
aufklärung und einer modernen debatte
einer modernen demokratie versteht die
ja immer in checks and balances also in
der diskussion in der aushandlung und
auch in der vermittlung liegt und nicht
so sehr in der bedingungslose
gefolgschaft die ja der charismatische
führer letztlich sie nur insinuiert oder
suggeriert es gut wäre ich glaube das
ist
expansys auch beim heldentum gibt also
ich konzentriere mich nicht so sehr auf
die heldentat eine einzige tat sondern
ich würde davon ausgehen dass kein held
allein kommt geht gar nicht denn
heldentum entsteht ja erst durch den
zuspruch
also das ist anders als wenn man der
erstbesteigung von geburtsland macht die
kann man ganz alleine machen und
hinterher kann man sagen man hat es
geschafft
ob man ein held ist hängt nicht von
einem selbst ab sondern von einem ganzen
gesellschaftlichen spiel
die rosa parks oder das irgendwann ist
dann kommt also diese an die bewerbung
die ist ja auch in dem moment noch
keinen helden keine heldin wenn sie da
nicht aufsteht in dem bus sondern sie
wird dann zu dieser figur die
anziehungskraft hat und die dann auch
nachfolger auf nach sich zieht und
anregt und anstachelt und in dem sinne
würde ich sagen zu dem helden gehört ein
ganzes soziales spiel und da sind dann
auch checks and balances am werk glaube
ich bloß offene eben elastische art und
weise da geht es dann zum beispiel darum
und es gibt ja die berühmten gefallenen
helden auch die dann ihren ruf ruinieren
ob die eben den sturm der zeit
überstehen ob die das dafür einstehen ob
die das einlösen diese haltung und das
wenn wenn sie dann irgendwie in einer
bewegung aktiv sind und deshalb glaube
ich es ist dann doch noch ein bisschen
konkreter werden was denn diese
heldenfigur die ihnen vorschwebt noch
einmal genau ausmacht kürzlich hat der
tages anzeiger eine geschichte getitelt
bezugnehmend auf ihr buch
da heißt es er kurz ist born natürlich
bezugnehmend auf sebastian kurz und die
frage ist es daraus wollen kurzes bonn
ist herr kurz jetzt sebastian kurz der
designierte oder zukünftige kanzler
wiederum von österreich 1 hält viele
leute würden ihn natürlich ein stück
weit aus heldenfigur sehen es auch
autoritär im sinne von er nimmt sich
diese rolle auch wenn man seinen
leistungsausweis anschaut dann kann man
geteilter meinung sein es hat der führer
dieser svp aber er hat natürlich auch
profitiert davon dass die fpö wiederum
österreich einiges verbockt hat
was würden sie jetzt sagen ist es ein
held und woran erkennen wir denn welchen
helden wir fordern sollen wenn wir die
demokratie im blick haben und deren wohl
also ein held erkennt man daran dass er
sich in gefahr begibt und dass er sich
für eine große sache einsetzt und damit
sich von den anderen ab
kurz gesagt ich finde und ich finde kurz
über kurz etwas gesagt dass kurzen gutes
beispiel ist für manches von dem was
frau kopitzsch gesagt hat denn es gibt
praktisch bei kurz natürlich nicht
irgendwie dass das phänomen dass er sich
in gefahr begeben hätte also insofern
fällt dadurch als held aber es ist so
dass er mit einem gefährlichen ding
jongliert und das ist das was ich was
man da als große sache bezeichnen kann
nämlich dass er sohn in seiner mischung
aus nationalismus und sich noch im
rahmen der demokratie bewegen
diese gefühle zu nutze macht die sich
darauf richten dass man doch jetzt in
der nation diese selbstbestimmung gegen
diese ganzen globalen abhängigkeiten
aufrechterhalten will
und da gibt es eine wunderbare bemerkung
des grossen schweizer historikers jacob
burckhardt über die nation weil die
nation ja immer diese helden referenz
war ja also sie starben den heldentod
und so und dann sagt ja ganz knapp die
nation eine große sache etwas unbedingt
es ist sie nicht
also er war sehr misstrauisch dagegen
nur auf der ebene dieser nation die
große sache zu preisen und die
demokratie ist immer über ihre grenzen
hinaus gegangen die menschenrechte in
der demokratie gelten nicht einfach nur
für bürger sondern es sind deshalb
braucht menschenrechte und das heißt die
demokratie hat etwas grenz sprengendes
und gleichzeitig stehen wir tatsächlich
folge ihnen da vor dem problem wie
organisieren wer demokratie heutzutage
wende
der nationalstaat irgendwie in die
defensive gerät und da haben sie ja eben
viel deutungsmuster noch einmal
vorgelegt und auch analysen betrieben
und ein punkt ist tatsächlich diese
frage wie gehen die um mit dem verlust
des nationalstaates oder bedrängnis
verlust kann man jetzt noch nicht sagen
ich habe das ja beschrieben jetzt mit
diesen globalen unternehmen die
transnational agieren die aushöhlung der
souveränität der einzelnen staaten und
diese sehnsucht das wieder rückgängig zu
machen es gab auch diesen slogan vom
trammplatz america craig mark lilla der
große analytiker aus den usa wenn es
eben diese nostalgie geht diese
rückwärtsgewandtheit hat auch betont
mike america greater gern ist ja nichts
anderes als die sehnsucht danach wieder
zurück ins goldene zeitalter
aber diese möglichkeit haben jedoch gar
nicht oder ja ich würde auch sagen die
möglichkeit haben wir nicht weil die
gefahr ist sehr groß dass er wie wilhelm
der zweite dann plötzlich sagen
das auto hat keine zukunft die zukunft
liegt bei der pferdekutsche
das heißt also wir müssen eigentlich
erkennen dass wir auf einem epochalen
umbruch also dass wir sozusagen uns
mitten in einer einer gesellschaftlichen
umwälzung befinden die nicht mehr
rückgängig gemacht werden kann also da
gibt es kein da ist da ist kein also wir
haben die tippingpoint schon über
überschritten und wir können nicht mehr
in die nationalstaatlichen gehäuse
zurück das heißt aber auch nicht dass
nationalstaaten jetzt plötzlich sinnlos
sind sondern sie sind eine form der
organisation in dem diese globale
gesellschaft operiert neben anderen also
neben nichtregierungsorganisationen
nehmen transnationalen unternehmen neben
der eu das heißt wir haben die figuren
sozusagen neu aufgestellt und der
nationalstaat ist eine von diesen
figuren aber nicht mehr die die alles
enthält aber was ich nicht so ganz
verstehe ist sie analysieren ja auch
willst du diesen populismus dann kommt
und was diese menschen bewegt und warum
die wie sie sagen so zornig sind weil
sich nämlich eben fürchten um diese um
diese verluste und diese ängste die sie
haben dass diese alten größen wie zum
beispiel nationen dann nicht mehr
bestand haben werden
zugleich habe man den eindruck die
populisten sind auch ein bisschen
angezählt also vorüber
im moment wirklich spricht sind globale
bewegung wie die klima jugend ja da sind
natürlich die zwei verschiedenen lager
wenn wir jetzt über klima sprechen haben
befinden wir uns in einer anderen
kollektive identität also das ist
natürlich auch eine bindung der
kosmopolitismus das heißt wir haben also
die obere mittelschicht die sich genau
in diesem kosmopolitischen milieu bewegt
und die eben auch eine kollektive
identität hat die also eine million
bildung darstellt meines erachtens die
auch post national ist ja weil sie eben
nicht mehr in den nationalen rahmen sich
zumindest nicht empfindet also dass sie
selber nationale färbungen haben ist
glaube ich unbestritten aber fakt ist
dass diese akademische mittelschicht
sich nicht mehr als national in dem
sinne empfindet wie die traditionelle
mittelschicht die wir in der alten
bundesrepublik zum beispiel oder in den
alten nationalstaatlichen
nachkriegsgeneration noch für
selbstverständlich gehalten haben
sondern diese mittelschicht die neue
erklärt ihre post nationale
universalität für ihre eigene
glaubensrichtung und dadurch ist die
blickrichtung auch global das heißt das
klima thema ist ein globales thema
genauso wie zum beispiel die finanzkrise
und die ist gar nicht mehr national zu
beschränken also und auch gar nicht
durch irgendwelche helden zum zu
meistern sondern das sind ja schon also
vernetzte probleme die letztlich ein
globales denken auch erforderlich machen
während die andere fraktion also die
jetzt eben zurück will zur nation sich
über diese nation formiert und gerade
eben die globalität dieser probleme gar
nicht wahrhaben will aus meiner sicht
darf ich wieder sprechen also mir fehlt
da ein wort wenn sie global und national
gegenüberstellen das wort lokal denn
also diese ich glaube tatsächlich dass
es klima dass das klimathema etwas ist
was jetzt nicht nur von den wie sie
gesagt haben urbanen
kosmopoliten aufgegriffen wird sondern
auch von den weinbauern im bündner
rheintal oder in im piemont oder in weiß
gott wo in der welt weil die einfach bei
ihrer ernte merken dass sie neue traum
brauchen oder so was also das heißt es
ist auch ein sehr lokales thema und die
das heißt also wir haben tatsächlich
einerseits nationale fragen andererseits
globale fragen zum glück ist es aber so
dass die bewegungen die sich zum
beispiel um diese globalen fragen drehen
und dazu gehört im moment des klima dazu
gehört aber eben auch snowden der für
mich auch eine ganz wichtige figur ist
bezogen auf überwachung und
datenaustausch und all diese dinge also
dass das gute ist dass diese globalen
bewegungen nicht einfach
also dass die eigentlich bei sehr vielen
menschen auch irgendwie energien
freisetzen und wenn man dann durch
helden ich beharre darauf einfach auch
so punkt kristallisationspunkte findet
an an denen man bei denen man merkt wenn
ich die tun was was ich mir selbst gar
nicht zugetraut hätte vielleicht
probiere es jetzt doch auch mal über
meine grenzen hinauszugehen
wenn wir wenn wir solche helden haben
dann ist das gerade auch die richtige
organisationsform für bewegung also ich
will ja keine eltern weil sie nicht im
gericht haben da sollen richter sitzen
aber wenn es um bewegung gilt dann
schnell kann man die schon gebrauchen
ich möchte das so gerne auch noch besser
verstehen worin eigentlich ihre ihre
sehnsucht oder ihre hoffnung gründet
heute wählt die schweiz ein neues
parlament das ist immer so der moment
ich finde das geradezu auch einen
feierlichen moment wo die menschen die
demokratie bestätigen können uns
gebrauch machen kann von ihren
demokratischen grundrechten
da hoffe ich sozusagen auf diese bürger
und bürgerinnen die diese rechte
wahrnehmen absolut sie hoffen auf helden
das schließt sich dort nicht aus das
heißt sie hoffen auf beides sehen sie
auch wenn das beispiel jetzt nicht aus
der schweiz stammt
irgendwer das verzeihen sondern aus dem
gros kanton wenn ein kleiner
bürgermeister in irgendeiner stadt in
bayern oder auch in ostdeutschland
und das sind ja wahre geschichten und
zwei dutzend fach mehrfach die reifen
zerschnitt kriegt die fenster
eingeworfen kriegt und kot in der post
im paket geliefert bekommt und in seinem
amt bleibt dann ist der eigentlich nur
ein bürgermeister aber er tritt nicht
zurück und er nimmt das alles in kauf
und das ist für mich hier ruhig so
einfach ich sage ja nicht dass deshalb
die leute nicht zur wahl gehen soll um
gottes willen das ist ja ein
bürgermeister also ich glaube das
problem was was wir haben was sie auch
haben mit dem helden begriff ist einfach
diese tonnenschwere last aus der
vergangenheit dass man dann immer nur an
diese fliegenden barone denkt oder an
irgendwelche anderen über über typen und
das ist aber auch ungerecht weil zum
beispiel die ganzen frauenrechtlerinnen
die im neunzehnten jahrhundert zum teil
umgebracht worden sind ja oder unzählige
andere die jetzt bei der
sklavenbefreiung aktiv waren und was der
teufel die die haben natürlich enorme
persönliche risiken in kauf genommen ja
wie nennen wir die denn darf und das ist
ja nicht ein widerspruch zu den
engagierten bürger
ich kann dem auch ganz viel abgewinnen
also dass sich so das was was peter
sloterdijk aus vertikal spannung
bezeichnet hat diese idee über sich
selbst heraus zu wachsen das große zu
wagen einer idee sich verpflichtet für
nun nicht lockerlassen und solche
menschen braucht die gesellschaft ja
tatsächlich den würden sie warum aber
auch nicht widersprechen oder dem würde
ich auf keinen fall widersprechen
die frage ist nur ob man mit dem helden
begriff weiter kommt also weil das was
sie beschreiben sind ja soziale
bewegungen das sind ja keine singulären
helden und der helden begriff der der
suggeriert sozusagen etwas singuläres
also eine einzel gestalt und eine
einzelhandlung also eine bestimmte tat
die sozusagen etwas bewegt und ein
individuelles risiko und die die
personen oder die personifizierung die
sie beschreiben von heldt
im hafen figuren die kommen ja nicht
ohne ihre bewegung aus das heißt es ist
eine ganze bewegung von frauen die sich
vielleicht eine führerin suchen die aber
überhaupt nicht singulär ist sondern die
praktisch gemeinsam mit den anderen
frauen eben diese bewegung bildet und
die gemeinsam auch risiken eingehen das
ist nicht eine einzelne gestalt die
jetzt aufgrund ihrer politischen
aktivitäten nachteile oder sehr riskante
beeinträchtigungen in kauf nehmen muss
sondern das sind tatsächlich kollektive
also das sind politische kollektive die
auch nur als sollte ich etwas ausrichten
können in demokratischen gesellschaften
sie sagen jetzt sie suchen sich eine
führungspersönlichkeit
das ist mir zu zu einseitiger prozess
ich meine das klingt so als hätte man da
20 zur auswahl und würde einfach kreisen
und dann tippt man auf die als wäre ist
eigentlich egal welche man nimmt es gibt
ja auch so was wie eine entgegenkommende
leistung derer die da die nase in den
wind stecken und praktisch so eine
vorleistungen erbracht wird und ich
fühle mich missverstanden wenn sie sagen
es geht um singuläre taten ein held
kommt nicht allein ein held ist gar
nichts wenn er nicht um eben diesen
zuspruch bekommt und natürlich ist es so
dass es dann darauf ankommt ist dieser
zuspruch gehorsam und gefolgschaft oder
ist dieser zuspruch ansporn dann ist es
aber ein streit um des kaisers bart also
weil ich würde sagen das ist sicherlich
dass es um eine wertegemeinschaft geht
also es geht im prinzip darum dass sich
praktisch eine bestimmte bewegung
erstmal herausbildet um bestimmte
überzeugungen also um bestimmte
überzeugung ja überhaupt zu vertreten ja
und das ist nichts was was jetzt eine
bestimmte person macht sondern das ist
das was ich im kollektiven prozess
herausbildet eine bestimmte widerstands
form wie wir zum beispiel ist hoffen
können dass ich vielleicht tatsächlich
irgendwann mal ein produktiver
widerstand gegen den neoliberalismus
formiert der dann aber sicherlich nicht
auf eine singuläre figur zu reduzieren
ist sondern eine bestimmte überzeugung
die sie schon lange lange formiert hat
in bestimmten bevölkerungsgruppen die
dann zum ausbruch kommt und die eine
kollektive
expression auch darstellt also die
praktisch eine eine kollektiven willen
und nicht einen einzelnen beschreibt und
so wie sie es beschrieben haben sind sie
ja im prinzip der chor ja sie würden ja
sagen das ist teil einer bewegung weil
ein held ist niemals allein sondern er
braucht oder sie braucht eine
anerkennung frau kopp ich sie haben mir
ja im vorfeld auch gesagt dass sie
denken denn die unsere welt anschauen
dann sind die störungslage sozusagen so
diffus und vernetzt will das ist fast
nicht möglich ist dass ein einzelner
hält sozusagen den ausschlag geben kann
dass sich das ändert zugleich merke ich
dann sofort auch wie ich manchmal dann
begeistert bin von dieser idee des
helden weil ich ein bisschen müde werde
und denke da muss man ja so lange warten
dann muss man ja einfach warten bis sich
diese kosten irgendwie lösen
um diese vorstellung dass man eine
person hat die sich dahin stellt wie
diese rosa parks und sagt so und jetzt
mache ich einfach mal was und die welt
wird mir folgen das hat natürlich auch
was sehr verführerisch ist also anders
gefragt wie kommen wir aus dieser
müdigkeit heraus den eindruck zu haben
das ist alles so komplex also ich so ein
modebegriff es ist alles so komplex ich
kann ja gar nichts machen
ja also natürlich kann man was machen
und natürlich hat herr thoma recht es
gibt die leute die beispielsweise wieder
bürgermeister dienen sie beschrieben
haben heroisch sind und etwas tun was im
alltag uns aus bestimmten zahlen raus
hält genauso wie zum beispiel ich in
meiner uni beobachten kann wie sich
jemand dafür einsetzt dass ein
bestimmter kollegen nicht unter bezahlt
wird das ist ja auch so was was er tut
und nicht ohne risiko das ist zum
beispiel so etwas wieder alltags
heroismus den sie auch beschreiben
aber die frage ist natürlich wie weit
reicht das was ein einzelner tut und ich
finde es ist nicht weiter verwunderlich
dass die beispiele in ihrem buch herr to
me meistens um zwei gruppen von menschen
kreisen oder aus zwei gesellschaftlichen
sphären kommen nämlich das eine ist die
sogenannte zivilcourage also da ist
jemand der sich einsetzt
dafür dass zum beispiel jemand anders
nicht verprügelt wird oder ihm gewalt
getan wird also wohl tatsächlich auch
jemand ganz entschlossen ein schreiben
kann und damit auch etwas riskiert und
dann als vorbild auch in der presse und
den medien sozusagen hingestellt wird
zurecht und die andere der andere
bereich ist dass der mediale bereich wie
beispielsweise kreta tonwerk die
tatsächlich es schafft über ihre
entschlossenheit auch etwas zu bewirken
ich will das auch gar nicht
herunterspielen aber in dem moment wo
wir wirklich etwas verändern wollen
bleibt uns also nicht erspart auch durch
das dickicht der institution zu gehen ja
also das gilt natürlich auch für
charismatische politiker die ja nun auch
nicht als charismatiker auf die welt
gekommen sind sondern sich in einer
partei nach oben arbeiten mussten oder
eben auch ihre gefolgsleute langsame
sachen ganz kurz ein beispiel anschauen
und dann kann er thomas sagen warum er
entweder diesen helden begriff nicht
teilt oder doch denkt dass von ihnen
rettung kommen könnte nämlich ein
solches erstes beispiel zivil courage
2015 in einem cewe haben drei
zugspassagiere einen mutmaßlichen
terroristen überwältigt der tgw fuhr von
amsterdam nach paris und die drei männer
wurden nachher wirklich heldenhaft
gefahr jetzt schauen wir uns das ganz
kurz an
konfettiregen und applaus für alex
gerlitz links spencer stone in der mitte
und anthony sandler die stadt sacramento
feiert drei schulfreunde
drei wochen zuvor sitzen die drei im
schnellzug von amsterdam nach paris hier
bilder aus dem spielfilm in dem sie ihre
geschichte selber nachspiel
plötzlich schießt ein mann um sich die
drei überwältigen den mutmaßlichen
terroristen
andere passagiere schließen sich ihnen
an ein passagier wird durch einen schuss
verletzt
die polizei nimmt den attentäter in
gewahrsam
das war ziemlich cool viele denken wir
wären traumatisiert aber das sind wir
nicht
das ist eine einzigartige situation denn
es ist niemand gestorben
zusammen einen terroristen verprügeln
was könnte es besseres geben und dann
durften wir es nochmals machen zusammen
mit klink ist wird wir schauen dass als
positive situation an und wir freuen uns
dass wir sie teilen können
die drei kriegen auszeichnungen zuhauf
barack obama verleiht ihnen die purple
heart medaille und francois hollande er
nennt die drei und dem passagier chris
norman zu ritter der französischen
ehrenlegion
[Applaus]
das ist doch dass man wenn es jetzt
erfolgen wäre denken würde vielleicht
aber wenn es wahr ist wird es sein und
man ist froh das ist es gibt man stelle
sich eine welt vor in der einfach
niemand mehr so was machen würde
das wäre bitter finden sie denn es gab
früher mehr helden also haben sie dieses
buch aufgeschrieben weil sie denken wir
leben in einer dann sagt jammer dieses
post heroische zeitzer wir leben in
einer zeit in der wir heldentum nicht
mehr adäquat würdigen
ich glaube dass die rede vom
postheroischen zeitalter eine lebenslüge
der moderne ist ich halte das für
totalen schwachsinn wenn ich das so hart
sagen darf aber ich glaube dass man das
theoretisch auch gut begründen können
was jetzt vielleicht zu weit führen
würde
man merkt es wird dann daran dass die
helden eben an verschiedenen stellen
hochkommen wieso korken in der badewanne
hochklappen eben im kino oder eben in
dieser multiplizieren von alltagshelden
und ich glaube dass wir daraus schließen
dürfen dass wir den begriff nicht
einfach oder dass das phänomen auch die
erfahrung über sich hinauszuwachsen
nicht einfach vernachlässigen dürfen und
apropos früher also natürlich früher gab
es eine ganze zeitung im weltkrieg voll
sie starben den heldentod sich haben den
heldentod also
von der schieren zahl her gab es dann
wahrscheinlich früher mehr helden jeder
der sich duellierte waren hält aber ich
will ja nicht einfach zählen ich will ja
die richtigen ja und sie sagen wir auch
wenn alle helden sind dann sind es keine
helden also die masse die kann sie nicht
sein
ja also ich sehe es ein bisschen anders
weil ich sehe dass auch weniger als als
bei ihm klingt es so ein bisschen
überzeitlich als ob es jede gesellschaft
ihre zahl oder ihre helden hervorbringt
und ich glaube dass unsere zeit die
helden nicht gerade ermutigt sagen wir
mal so und daher würde ich schon auch
frau bleisch recht geben dass wir in
einem so genannten postheroischen
zeitalter insofern leben als helden die
tatsächlich etwas tun was was nicht
konform ist oder etwas was vielleicht
auch über über sagen wir mal
individuellen bezüge impliziert also
etwas tut was der gesellschaft im ganzen
der allgemeinheit wird oft gesagt
kriegen ja die opfer sicher auf denkt
doch mal lieber an dich selbst was
glaubst du denn wer darüber ist das gut
ist das gut nein aber ich sage das als
gesellschafts wissenschaftlerin und
nicht als moralphilosophen ja also ich
sage natürlich haben sie recht es wäre
schön es wäre anders aber diese zeit in
der wir leben erzählt uns doch wir
sollen uns die ganze zeit flexibel
verhalten das heißt ja nichts anderes
als dass wir nicht unseren werten folgen
sondern dem was gerade opportun ist und
unter da fehlt ja genau diese komponente
und ich kann einerseits nur zustimmen
und sagen es wäre schön wir hätten so
was wie leute die sich mehr an an dem
allgemeininteresse orientieren das heißt
ein bisschen mehr helden tun würden sie
auch befürworten insofern dass sie
ziehen ihr bei der these des
neoliberalismus die sich am anfang an
gebracht haben insofern wie in einer
zeit leben in der wir zwar alle unter
bauer wettbewerb versuchen uns zu
optimieren
aber eigentlich eben auch ein
konformitätsdruck herrscht nämlich ein
optimieren alle auf das gleiche hinaus
auf leistung hin getrieben nicht das
extravagant täters heldenhaft moralische
suchen zum beispiel genau das eine
bedingt das andere das heißt diese art
von wettbewerbsdruck der hat ja schon
auch eine eine funktion der auszeichnung
also man nennt es ja dann auch teilweise
in den sozial
wissenschaften winner takes it all das
derjenige der sich durchsetzt gegen alle
anderen der bekommt alles die ganze
aufmerksamkeit das ganze geld und das
ist ja die situation in der wir sind das
heißt wenn wenn es jemandem gelingt sich
auszuzeichnen
dann ist es meistens eben indem er sich
im wettbewerb durchsetzt und das sind ja
auch die hohen die gefeiert werden also
unternehmer oder im alltag das
unternehmerische selbst aber das sind
nicht mehr leute die dem allgemeinwohl
inso verfolgen als ihr das hätte ich
etwas riskieren oder sie tatsächlich
etwas gegen diese spielregeln tun oder
daraus ausbrechen sondern sie folgen ja
genau dem was ihnen die gesellschaft
sagt und in dem maße wie also
auszeichnungen angehen vergeben werden
die sich besonders gut anpassen und
nicht an die die die normen verletzen
oder die also ein nonkonformismus im
dienste des allgemein und so willig
erhält verstehen üben dass die also gar
nicht so richtig wahrgenommen wird
sondern wer sich auf hat jetzt selbst
sind sie wahrscheinlich gleicher meinung
oder also ich halte nichts davon
wirtschaftsführer als helden zu
bezeichnen obwohl es da eine große
tradition gibt und auch so eine
seine bereitwilligkeit steve jobs oder
so zu heroisieren und zwar weil es eben
da diese überblendung gibt von zwei
dingen das eine ist die eigene
gewinnabsicht und das andere ist eine
unternehmung also unternehmen kann man
ja vieles man kann tolle sachen
unternehmen man kann große dinge bauen
und so aber da immer diese diese
gewinnmitnahme diese gewinnabsicht bei
diesen menschen im vordergrund stehen
muss das ist ja sozusagen berufsbild der
ganzen sache geht es gar nicht dass da
jemand über sich hinaus denkt so richtig
er muss sich immer bremsen mir kommt er
so ein bisschen so vor wie jemand der
sich mit irgendwelchen großtaten
[Musik]
auszeichnen will und dann vielleicht
sagt jetzt habe ich ein kind aus dem see
gerettet und dann nebenbei spielt welche
belohnungen abgreifen kann also und
dieses element der belohnung ist im
kapitalismus eingebaut
und deshalb gibt es eben diese tendenz
zur individualisierung bei der leyen
übrigens das ist ja auch interessant wie
sie gesagt haben es oft so ist dass man
selbst besser dasteht nur dann wenn der
andere schlechter da oder besser gesagt
man versucht besser dazustehen
und dazu beizutragen dass der andere
irgendwie auch nach bisschen nach unten
geschoben wird wären zum beispiel es für
den helden
wenn der jetzt ich nehme mir dann so ein
dummes beispiel ein kind aus einem
brennenden haus rettete für den ist
jetzt nicht entscheiden dass die anderen
dadurch schlecht aussehen dabei denkt da
gar nicht dran war schon so was wie ein
bewundert zu werden der datus aufwerten
zu können dass sie auch eben wieder
dieses statusverlust etwas was viele
haben viele haben angst nicht mehr
gesehen zu werden und dann so ehrenorden
zu kriegen das ist ja erstmal eigentlich
eine schöne sache
ich würde aber gerne mit ihnen doch auch
noch darüber sprechen wollen eigentlich
alle gerne helden sein sind alle dazu
berufen sozusagen herausstechen zu
wollen und mit ihm gerne noch einmal
eine kurze szene angucken aus dem film
von monty python das leben des brian
da gibt es nämlich eine heldenfigur
erfolgt eine große masse aber die
heldenfigur möchte gar nicht dass man
ihr folgt und zivil die macht sie nach
hause schicken die masse wiederum möchte
aber gerne masse bleiben und auf gar
keinen fall individuell sein
schauen wir uns das ganz kurz an diese
wunderbare szene
[Applaus]
ich habe ein oder zwei dinge zu sagen
hör zu ihr versteht das alles falsch es
ist wirklich nicht nötig dass ihr mir
folgt es ist völlig unnötig einen
menschen zu folgen die nicht bei kennt
ihr müsst nur an euch selbst denken ihr
seid doch alle individuen und ihr seid
alle völlig verschieden ich nicht regne
man muss lachen wenn man sieht was ist
denn eigentlich so lustig das passt ja
wunderbar zudem übrig was wir vorher
hatten weil da jemand eigentlich die
unbedingte gefolgschaft zurückweist und
den leuten befiehlt ungehorsam zu sein
und dann stimmen sie ihm zu und sind
damit genau gehorsam also das ist das
paradox dass und natürlich es besonders
lustig wenn er sagt sie sollen nur an
sich selber denken weil da haben wir
gewissermaßen individualismus eingebaut
nicht unbedingt den neoliberalismus aber
den individualismus und wenn die das war
dem sprechchor sagen jeder denken nur an
sich selbst dann kommt es einem nicht so
vor dass es war bestimmt und das darin
liegt die komik und es ist aber ein
schönes beispiel dieser wunderbare
pseudo jesus da oben bei monty python
dafür dass es auch figuren gibt die
eigentlich mit der gefolgschaft hadern
also die eigentlich gar nicht denn die
gar nicht wollen dass ihnen gefolgt wird
ein anderes wichtiges beispiel aus der
philosophie wir sind ja hier stand schon
der philosophie ist ein ethisches
zarathustra der auch extrem allergisch
reagiert auf die vorstellung dass ihnen
jetzt alle massen folgend wird sollten
und das will ähnlich aber die frage ist
ja trotzdem wollen die eigentlich
herausstechen hält sein auch diese
verantwortung übernehmen oder wollen wir
mehr zur gemeinschaft gehören und
vielleicht auch versinken in einem
kollektiv und das ist auch etwas was in
ihrer analyse
eine große rolle spielt frau koppetsch
dass sie sagen es gibt natürlich auch so
eine sehnsucht nach einer
vergemeinschaftung nennen sie es nämlich
die sehnsucht danach wieder irgendwo
dazuzugehören und gerade nicht einzeln
zu sein ja genau und ich glaube das
können wir auch tatsächlich verstellen
dass dass es diesen trend gibt also
gerade in abkehr von dem was der so
genannte neoliberalismus uns zumutet
nämlich die extreme initialisierung die
so lange funktioniert solange auch die
liga toren wieder ralf dahrendorf das
mal genannt hat funktionieren also
ligatoren das sind ja die bindungen also
beispielsweise die soziale klasse das
geschlecht die herkunft die
zugehörigkeiten die wir über die wir
verfügen und die eigentlich auch so
etwas wie unsere identität ausmachen und
im zuge der globalisierung erodieren ja
diese zugehörigkeiten oftmals und die
frage ist was was tritt an die stelle
und wenn nichts an die stelle tritt also
wenn alles nur noch im auflösen ist im
sich auflösen ist dann dann kommt es
eben zu diesem ganz großen mächtigen
wunsch der zugehörigkeit vielleicht auch
zur nation zu einem kollektiv zu einem
zu einem größeren selbst und hier spielt
natürlich auch dass die helden gestalt
möglicherweise eine rolle
bloß weniger auf der angebotsseite als
auf der nachfrageseite das heißt der
wunsch vielleicht tatsächlich mit so
einer charismatischen führungsfigur zu
verschmelzen oder dass diese
führungsfigur ein irgendwie das abnehmen
könnte was man selber auferlegt bekommt
nämlich sich permanent entscheiden zu
müssen unter unsicherheit
eigentlich gar nicht wissen was einen
eigentlich unter welchen bedingungen
erwartet also die die konfusion die ja
auch im moment herrscht dass man gar
nicht mehr weiß woran soll man denn
eigentlich hat sich in seinen
erwartungen richten was wir mal wo soll
man sich also ein brian der einem sagt
wo es lang geht aber gleichzeitig stellt
sich ja nicht nur die frage wollen drei
hände und sagt wo es lang geht sondern
auch was machen die mit unseren eigenen
heldenhaften gelüsten die ja eben nicht
nur schlecht sein müssen sondern die
eben auch uns vorantreiben können also
ich glaube dass helden zwei wirkungen
haben können entweder sie entlasten oder
sie stacheln an und die entlastenden
helden die muss man mit misstrauen
besichtigen sowie sieht es gerade
beschrieben haben also ein held geht vor
und man selbst lehnt sich ins sofa
zurück und sagt der kümmert sich drum
und dann kann man höchstens noch
sozusagen an diesem helden wachsen indem
man in frenetischem applaus sicht
gewissermaßen in dessen windschatten
steht und ist dadurch dann leichter hat
zu folgen und es gibt aber das ist eben
und das wird schon seit jahren darüber
wird übrigens nicht erst jetzt heute
gestritten stande sein dass schon wann
sondern schon seit jahrhunderten es gibt
auch andere beschreibungen des
heldentums und die sind dann er eben
unter der überschrift anstacheln oder
auf reizen zu sehen nämlich dass helden
anderen menschen demonstrieren was alles
möglich ist und das wird dann vielleicht
von uns also von normalen menschen wie
mir nicht beherzigt und wir schaffen es
vielleicht nicht wir kriegen die kurve
nicht aber wir vielleicht doch und diese
möglichkeit zu eröffnen dieses fensters
aufzustoßen
das führt dann eben nicht dazu dass man
sich selbst ausruht sondern dass man
denkt wow da ist ja doch was möglich und
dann und und wenn wir jetzt über soziale
bewegungen sprechen
dann werden wir feststellen dass es
immer dieses wechselspiel gegeben hat es
gab eine unzufriedenheit eine kollektive
unzufriedenheit und es gab dann
bestimmte momente die so als zünder
gewirkt
wo sich eben einzelne personen an die in
den wind gestellt haben und die die
haben dann mobilisiert und diese
mobilisierende wirkung ist es die mich
interessiert nicht so sehr die die die
sozusagen verehrung dieser
ausserordentlichen person sondern deren
tatsächlich deren politische wirkung und
die können wir gut gebrauchen glaube ich
also meine frage ist dann doch aber auch
wie organisieren wir uns als
gesellschaft um dieses spezifische
heldentum das eben der demokratie helfen
könnte eben wie zu befeuern also können
wir eine art nährboden schaffen wir
sowas weil rein nur der wettbewerb wär's
ja nicht ich glaube es gibt zwei
stichworte die helden feindlichen
gewissermaßen und die heutzutage sehr
dominieren das eine ist wettbewerb weil
sie wie sie gesagt haben dass andere
satz war also der wettbewerb sagt jeder
soll sich um sich selbst kümmern und der
sachzwang sagt es gibt gar nicht
menschen die sich um irgendwas kümmern
sondern prozesse institution abläufe
strukturen in denen dann irgendwas
geregelt wird ebenso ohne fast ohne
menschliches zutun
und das heißt wir haben so eine
kollektive abstrakte anonyme ebene die
in der es ums ganze geht und wir haben
die individuen die um sich selbst für
sich selbst kämpfen und was dazwischen
fehlt was aber kernbestandteil der
demokratie ist es fehlt nicht aber was
ich jetzt noch nicht erwähnt habe und
was gern bestandteil der demokratie ist
ist das was sie haben vorhin von
zivilcourage gesprochen was dann auch
zivilgesellschaft genannt wird was
einfach der lebendige wie man im um 1800
gesagt hätte politische körper ist in
der in dem sich menschen
vergemeinschaften zusammentun um ziele
streiten sich einsetzen also handeln
wenn sie frau koppetsch vorwerfen sie
denke in ihrer analyse zu sehr in diesem
sachzwang ich glaube dass es zum teil
einfach einen fruchtbaren fruchtbares
konzert von disziplin ist dass die
soziologen er den kalten blick haben
ebenso beschreiben wie sieht es
vorhergesagt haben und nicht moral
philosophisch argumentieren und das
moralphilosophen sozialphilosophen
politische philosophen eher dazu neigen
eben moralische ziele zu benennen und zu
begründen und vielleicht ist es so eine
art dvd formation professionell auf
meiner seite
oder vielleicht ist es aber auch eine
deformation auf uns unserer beider
seiten die harmonische lösung wäre es
ist einfach so eine art aufteilung von
aufgaben im konzert der disziplin
fühlen sie sich verstanden wie
verstanden womit stimmt dass dieser
sagen jetzt mal kalte blick das ja nicht
böse gemeint welche analytische
gesellschafts blick der blick vielleicht
eher darauf wie die systeme
funktionieren letztlich auch die
sachzwänge und versucht von daher die
lösung zu denken währenddessen der
philosoph das individuum sieht und die
hoffnung auch mit dem individuum
verbindet dass dieses individuum
sozusagen aus seinem körper heraus dreht
und das große war das würde ich so nicht
sehen also was heißt das große wagen
also ich möchte nochmal auf das was ich
am anfang gesagt habe zu bekommen ich
glaube dass erstens dieses thema helden
sehr missverständlich ist weil sie immer
wieder auf normative grundposition
kommen wo sie sagen sie müssen
unterscheiden zwischen guten und
schlechten helden weil sie sagen
lutz bachmann ist ja nicht unser held
und donald trump auch nicht also ronald
schreiber auch nicht und wir müssen
jetzt also eine anzahl von helden
zusammen suchen die wir den wir
vorbehaltlos zustimmen können und das
halte ich für problematisch aber das ist
was ich alles schon damals als problem
dabei finde ist dass das dass das helden
das ruft eine assoziationskette auf die
glaube ich gar nicht von ihnen so
gemeint ist sondern sie meinen ja im
prinzip schon so etwas wie kollektives
handeln
und da bin ich mit mit antonia auch
d'accord da will ich sagen ja natürlich
geht es darum dass wir was verändern
müssen und mein thema sind ja die
sozialen bewegungen und wir haben jetzt
also ein
eine gattung von sozialen bewegungen die
nenne ich reaktionäre protestbewegung
die ist natürlich überhaupt nicht gut
für die demokratie aber das heißt nicht
dass wir nicht auch bewegungen
wiederfinden können die vielleicht
progressiv sind aber nichtsdestotrotz
handelt es sich um bewegung wir können
nicht mit einzelnen helden kommen und
aus meiner sicht ist gerade das
missverständnis was das thema helden
auslöst dass es sich um einzelne
individuen handel die jetzt durch
irgendeine bestimmte heldentat etwas
verändern können und wir waren gerade
wieder dabei
über zivilcourage zu reden und wieder
dabei feuerwehrmänner unseren stars das
sind alles für wirkliche helden aber sie
haben mit unserer demokratie nicht viel
zu tun und da wo es tatsächlich darum
geht die gesellschaft zu ändern in der
wir leben da kommen wenn dich mit
feuerwehrmännern weiter naja etwa 1000
der in meinem buch eine große rolle
spielt und den sie dankenswerterweise
auch auf das große schrauben wollten mit
dem wir begonnen haben auf das denkmals
ross ist natürlich kein feuerwehrmann
sondern ein politischer hält und ein in
der demo ein in der demokratie in die
demokratie eingreifen da hält er sich
auf die grundwerte der amerikanischen
verfassung beruf und so weiter und so
fort also das heißt wir kommen nicht
drum rum übrigens egal ob wir bei helden
reden oder über irgendetwas anderes dann
irgendwann auf die frage zu kommen vom
gut und schlecht also das ist bei
sozialen bewegungen so dass es bei
helden so das spricht nicht gegen den
begriff hält es ist vielleicht im
deutschsprachigen raum und in der sehr
der gleichheit und der bescheidenheit
verpflichteten schweiz irgendwie ein
problematischer begriff als in
frankreich oder auch in amerika oder so
also in demokratischen in demokratischen
tradition
wir kommen nicht drum rum wenn wir
solche begriffe benutzen irgendwann die
frage nach gut und schlecht zu stellen
und das ist immer schwierig zu
beantworten bei der sozialen bewegung
ebenso wie beim heroismus aber
unvermeidlich etwas ist ja auch noch
interessant nämlich sich zu überlegen
von welchem menschenbild gehen sie
eigentlich beide aus weil sie sagen hat
oma an einer stelle
das ist mir so eine erinnerung geblieben
es geht darum und das ist der sinn des
lebens auch das leben richtig zu führen
und nicht vor sich hin zu vegetieren
und dann merkt man ja schon sofort auch
schauen was natürlich die bürokratie der
fachzweige für sie große feinde sind
und ich habe mich dann gefragt worum
geht es eigentlich bei ihnen was wäre
der sinn des lebens der individuen in
ihrem buch jetzt nicht der zornigen
individuen aber sie muss eine
gesellschaft beschaffen sein dass es den
menschen gut geht dass sie ihren sinn
finden können
ich glaube dass es sehr gut wäre und das
habe ich auch in ersten kapiteln
dargelegt wenn das politische
zurückkehren würde in der gesellschaft
und nicht erhält sondern das gefühl und
zwar das kollektive gefühl dass diese
gesellschaft gestaltbar ist das heißt
dass wir handlungsspielräume haben dass
wir über sachen debattieren und dass wir
zum beispiel über über dinge reden
können die die beispielsweise passieren
im zuge der der nt dosierung des der
gesellschaft also beispielsweise der der
ablehnung von also das abnehmen von
werten dass werte zum beispiel nicht
mehr verbindlich sind nehmen wir das
beispiel pflegeberufe die also gezwungen
werden in einer sehr engen takt um zu
funktionieren also nach markt prinzipien
und nicht mehr danach nach dem anderen
gesichtspunkten also das was der der zu
pflegende eigentlichen bedürfnisse hat
oder nehmen wir die wissenschaft die
nach indikatoren funktioniert die wie so
ne art planwirtschaft sich über die
selbstbindung der wissenschaftler also
wissenschaftler haben ja eigentlich ein
älteres sie wollen ja etwas forschen wir
wollen etwas wissen
und wenn ich sage dass mein ideal
besteht darin dass wir die
gestaltbarkeit der gesellschaft wider so
diskussion stellen und sich mal
überlegen wie wir in unseren eigenen
alltagswelten gesellschaft wieder
zurückholen können als begriff dann hat
das glaube ich nicht viel mit helden zu
tun sondern mit der frage wie können wir
in unseren institutionen einwirken und
zwar so dass wir das hier praktisch
autonomie zurück bekommen also die
freiheit ist in meinem sinne
da treffen sie sich dann wieder
vielleicht zum schluss wir haben ja
versprochen dass wir die gesellschaft
sprechen wollen und darüber was sie
eigentlich brauchen und ich glaube wir
können nicht über hält
sprechen ohne nicht doch auch noch
bertolt brecht zu erwähnen der in dem
stück einem galileo galilei dass sie
auch zitieren so sagen die beiden
figuren gegeneinander antreten lässt der
schüler der der und also eher sehr
unglücklich zu seinem meister sozusagen
sagt unglücklich das land das keine
helden hat weil galileo jahr wieder ruft
seine meinung und er der dann wieder
spricht und sagt unglücklich das land
das helden nötig hat zum schluss ganz
kurz wer hat recht
dragovic naja also unglücklich das land
das hält nötig hat weil eine demokratie
ist eine kollektive veranstaltung und in
dem augenblick wo ich sozusagen meine
rettung nur noch in den heldentum sehe
habe ich eigentlich schon als kollektiv
veranstaltung gesellschaft verloren
abgesehen davon dass brecht
interessanterweise überhaupt nicht
gemeint hat dass er auf der seite derer
stand die sagen unglücklich das war das
einzige den artig an ihrem buch das ist
überraschend weil alle denken brecht
hätte sich auf die seite galileis
geschlagen muss ich mich natürlich auf
die gegenseite schlagen und zwar glaube
ich tatsächlich dass ein land
unglücklich ist das keine helden hat ich
glaube dass die helden nicht allein
selig machend sind dass sie aber
gebraucht werden weil es einfach diese
ungeheure versuchung gibt freisetzt über
sich hinauszuwachsen und das und weil
sie handeln und demokratie ist viel
enger ans handeln als eine institution
geworden
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch danke sehr
nächste woche geht hier um einen
richtigen helden nämlich um alexander
von humboldts den großen wissenschaftler
der bereits vor 200 jahren vor dem
klimawandel gewarnt hat zu gast ist
briefpost die preisgekrönte umbaut
spezialistin andrea wulz und jetzt
geht's ab zur demokratie susanne wille
empfängt sie im wahlstudio mit ersten
hochrechnungen eine gute woche bis bald
[Musik]